- What sort of thing do you like to eat?
- Excellent question.
Green eggs and ham, it's
the dish that cannot mish.
- I'm vegan.
- Oh, I'm so sorry, I didn't realize.
How long have you known?
- [Sam] Try some?
- Ugh, no.
- They're surprisingly
good with the mouse.
- I will not eat them with a mouse.
I'm fine without mush.
- I don't want to eat them
either, you filthy son of a
(squeaking)
(giggling)
- Captain Bigman, we were taken out
by a dastardly band of
accomplices armed with WMDs.
- Weaponized melon devices?
- It was cantaloupe!
Oh, the horror, the disguise!
- The garbage fruit.
(glass breaking)
It's like 90% of every fruit salad.
- I know, right?
- And if Sandra knew I took the--
- Oh, right, your chick.
- Sandra is no one's chick.
She's very much her own
hen and I respect that.
- From one feminist to
another, that's very admirable.
- Gosh, it doesn't even
feel like we're moving.
- Oh, the park and ride
is deceptively fast.
(upbeat music)
- Why did you drive your car into a lake?
- Oh, it wasn't my car.
It belonged to the bad guys.
They would have tracked
it, so I had to lake it.
What's important is that nobody got hurt.
Everybody's safe.
(playful music)
- Hey kids!
- [Kids] Daddy!
- Did it just get dark all of a sudden?
- (screaming) Swim for your lives!
(screaming)
(crashing)
(bubbling)
(crying)
- No harm, no foul.
- [Mother Fish] Let's get a head count.
- Can we get more blankets over here?
- One fish, two fish, and
there's red fish and blue.
(suspenseful music)
(squeaking)
(lively music)
- The guard is on duty.
Everything is under control, including me.
- A fox guarding the henhouse?
Well, that's progressive.
Woo, we're home free.
Everyone knows goats can't climb.
(yelling)
- What kind of wildlife expert are you?
Goats are known especially
for their climbing.
- That is an outdated stereotype
and I prefer not to perpetuate it.
- You haven't even evolved as a species
and you think you're better than us?
(screaming)
- [All] Huh?
- You still live in a shabby nest
made of mud and leaves
and who knows what else.
(grunting)
And I mean, you seem
to have a remedial
semblance of a social order,
but you're hardly civilized.
Have you even developed an alphabet?
(grunting)
- Keep doing that.
(growling)
- Keep doing what?
- Whatever that is,
keep doing it. (yelling)
(growling)
(screaming)
- Seriously, what have
you done with your lives?
(screaming)
♪ I lived a life of humble joys ♪
♪ My wife and child were my salvation ♪
♪ It was a time of poverty ♪
♪ That starved both man and mouse across ♪
♪ The nation ♪
- [Narrator] Sam and Guy crawled through
five fuzzball fields of funk
(splashing)
and they finally made their way out.
(chuckling) Who'da thunk?
- (laughing) Do you feel that rain, Guy?
That sweet cleansing rain!